قالت الكتيبه الثاله عش من فرقه غلاني في
الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
41 من الكتيبه قتلوا يوم السبت الاسود في
اشاره الى هجوم حركه حماس يوم السابع من
اكتوبر وذكرت الكتيبه ان سبعه من
المقاتلين بينهم قائد الكتيبه الث عش
المقدم نومر جرينبرج قتلوا في واحده من
اصعب المعارك في قطاع
غزه
كان الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن مقتل ضابط
واصابه
21 ضابطا وجنديا اخرين بجروح وذلك خلال
المعارك في شمال قطاع غزه يرتفع بذلك
العدد المعلن رسميا لقتلى الجيش
الاسرائيلي منذ بدء العمليه البريه في غزه
الى
174 عسكريا كما يرتفع العدد الاجمالي
المعلن لقتلى الجيش الاسرا
منذ السابع من اكتوبر الماضي الى
502 بين ضابط وجندي وفي الاثناء اعلن
الجيش كذلك ان
431 عسكريا جريحا لا يزالون يتلقون العلاج
في المستشفيات الاسرائيليه وان بينهم
44 في حاله
صعبه وينضم ال الينا من تل ابيب مراسل
الجزيره محمد خيري محمد اذا ضع لنا كل هذه
الاخبار من الجانب الاسرائيلي في سياقها
لو سمحت واذا كان هناك اي مستجد من جانبك
تفضل نعم بدايه من المتوقع ان تنطلق خلال
الساعات القريبه القادمه بعد قليل ابتداء
من بعد قليل مظاهرات
لذوي المحتجزين الاسرائيليين في قطاع غزه
وذلك في دوار الرهائن هنا في مدينه تل
ابيب وكذلك من المتوقع ان تشهد مدن
اسرائيليه كثيره هذه الليله ايضا مظاهرات
واسعه النطاق تطالب باقاله رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين النتنياهو هذا الحراك
المستمر منذ السابع في اكتوبر وحتى هذا
اليوم
لازال ياخذ شكلا متطورا ومتسع طيله الوقت
مع مع استمرار الايام وفي ظل ايه مساعي ال
ذوي المخطوفين المحتجزين ايضا
الاسرائيليين الى الضغط على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه من اجل عقد صفقه تبادل اسرى
مع حركه المقاومه الاسلاميه حماس ايضا هذا
ياتي في ظل استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي على
قطاع غزه قبل قليل اشتدت يعني نطاق القصف
على مخيم البريج في المنطقه الوسطى في
قطاع غزه وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي ايضا انه
سيعمق
عملياته العسكريه والبريه والقصف الجوي
ايضا في منطقه مدينه خان يونس جنوبي قطاع
غزه وكذلك قال الجيش الاسرائيلي اليوم انه
استطاع الدخول الى مقر استخباراتي تابع
لحركه حماس في قلب مدينه خان يونس وادعى
انه استولى على مستندات غايه في الاهميه
كما يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي وهو يؤكد انه
سيستمر في عمليته العسكريه الى جنوب
قطاع غزه طبعا ياتي هذا كما قلنا في ظل
اشتداد ايضا القصف الجوي الاسرائيلي وكذلك
القصف المدفعي الاسرائيلي على المناطق
الشماليه ايضا لقطاع غزه والتي كما يبدو
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي لم يستطع حتى هذه
اللحظه حسم المعارك الدائره في المنطقه
الشماليه على يعني نقيض ما كان يقول في
السابق انه استطاع حسم المعارك في مناطق
مدينه غزه ومناطق الشمال من القطاع
واشتداد هذا القصف وكذلك المعارك وكذلك ما
ياتي من المقاومه الفلسطينيه يشير الى ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي حتى هذه اللحظه لم يستطع
فعليا حسم هذه المعارك هذه الليله ستكون
يعني ساخنه ايضا على صعيد المشهد
الاسرائيلي في ظل الضغط الذي يمارس على
الحكومه الاسرائيليه من قبل المجتمع وكذلك
من قبل عائلات المحتجزين الاسرائيليين وفي
ظل التسريبات التي تشير الى خلافات حاده
داخل مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي خاصه بين رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي ووزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي وايضا اشارت بعض الانباء التي
نقلتها صحيفه دعوت احرونوت قبل قليل الى
ان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي منع رئيس جهاز
الموساد وكذلك رئيس جهاز الشاباك الامن
العام من لقاء وعقد لقاءات مع وزير الدفاع
بما يتعلق في القضايه الامنيه والعسكريه
وكذلك قضايا تبادل الاسرى والى اين وصلت
هذه الصفقه في مراحلها وياتي ذلك بعد
اسبوع واحد من كشف الصحف الاسرائيليه ان
نتنياهو فعليا كان قد منع رئيس جهاز
الموساد من لقاء وزير الدفاع والتحدث عن
صفقات تبادل الاسرى وعن خطوات التي تقوم
بها الحكومه الاسرائيليه من اجل ابرام
صفقه تبادل اسرى هناك تعتيم واضح من قبل
مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي وخاصه من قبل رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي على قضيه صفقه تبادل
الاسرى وكذلك على قضيه الهدنه في ظل توارد
انباء كثيره في الاعلام الاسرائيلي حول
اقتراب ربما او الحصول على اشارات تتعلق
في اقتراب ابرام صفقه ما مقابل فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه وهذه
الصفقه تتضمن الافراج في على عده مراحل عن
ايم محتجزين اسرائيليين وكذلك هدنه قد
تستمر في المرحله الاولى لمده شهر في قطاع
غزه اذا ستكون هذه الليله كما يبدو حاميه
الوطيس خاصه في المدن الاسرائيليه
واشتداد الهبه الشعبيه الاسرائيليه التي
تطالب باقاله بنيامين نتنياهو وكذلك التي
تطالب بالافراج عن المحتجزين من قطاع غزه
اشكرك محمد خيري مراسلنا من تل ابيب على
كل هذه
التفاصيل